how you doing very well so thank you I
just want to start by saying I thought
you did a tremendous job with this I'm
so impressed this is your first feature
I'm just curious how you effin did this
because I think you really did such an
amazing job in a weird way without
knowing at all the short films I made
was you know it was a real sort of
preparation for this film my first film
that I that I had made was called as Adi
and it was about the plight of Afghan
refugees and the outback detention
centers in warmer in South Australia I
was studying law I didn't study film I
studied law in Australia and I'd read in
the newspaper a lot about you know how
the refugees that were coming to
Australia really had sinister intentions
and this was all in the news media in my
readings in law you know I saw a very
difference tale I saw that you know
these were people running from you know
genuine hardship violence and terror and
I felt it was a story that really needed
to be told I've read a lot of the court
case transcripts and testimonies where
they had gone to the refugee Review
Tribunal in Australia and this is not a
story that was getting out there so I
had gone with this a long answer but
Auckland it's I had gone with a with a
camera team down to the warmer a
detention centre where there was meant
to be a protest a peaceful protest it
turned out to be a riot and the and the
detainees on the inside who suffered
really horrific conditions pulled apart
their bunk beds and broke open the fence
and over a hundred escaped and we got
this on as footage on 16 millimeter
footage and and you know it was just you
know such compelling stories of no tales
of hardship and oppression but also of
people just you know trying to sort of
find a better life and we used a lot of
this rule life unusual footage that we
shot ourselves into what became as rd
which was a short film about of afghan
father trying to protect this son the
reason I bring that up is because that
you know that technique of blending
together
footage together with narrative footage
of something which ended up serving us
very well in hotel mumbai we didn't have
you know the the budget or the
inclination to try and recreate
everything and so you know to try and
get a sense of authenticity and realism
into the film beyond the scripting
characters you know came through pouring
through hundreds of hours of footage of
the actual Mumbai attacks second to that
I made a film called the palace which
some set during the 1974 invasion of
Cyprus the Turkish invasion of Cyprus is
a true story about a very young mother
trying to protect her children and a
young soldier forced to kill against his
will and it had a lot of traumatic
internal similarities to her to Mumbai
it was also really difficult and crazy
logistical effort shooting along the
United Nations Green Line in Cyprus and
the same team members that we used to
make those films ended up coming onto
her to Mumbai so my cinematographer Nick
Matthews who's from my local hometown of
Adelaide Australia has shot all my short
films came on to do this Julie Ryan who
produced the palace came on to do Hotel
Mumbai and so you know all of these
factors I think subconsciously did come
together and you know it was a training
ground in a way a bit unknowingly yeah
that led us into this movie that was so
tell about one thing that I thought that
you did such a brilliant job which was
blending all sides of this showing all
sides and you you really showed how the
terrorists were easily prime targets for
radicalization could you sort of talk
about that we went through over 3,000
pages of court case transcripts of Ajmal
Kasab the sole surviving gunman and this
included his video confession and he
also included wiretaps or not why
attached but phone intercepts that were
made between the terrorists and their
handlers back in in Pakistan and these
intercepts by the Indian security
services really gave a blow-by-blow
account of what the terrorists were
being told and what they were saying to
one another throughout the duration of
the attacks and those intercepts
together with thousands of pages of
court materials which went through
the where they came from and the sort of
impoverished backgrounds and you know
and the the difficulties they had
themselves first you know really really
allowed us to get into the sort of
psychology of what it drove you know
what drove these young men to terror and
it's the same as as in many of the case
of many extremists it's bred by
ignorance by lack of education and
frankly by sociopaths who whichever
ideology they're spouting they're
looking to get you know naive people to
do their bidding and that was the case
with with what happened in Mumbai these
were extremists first and foremost and
the film is really a plea for peace you
know and a denouncement of it you know
any kind of violence against you know
against people for any means
you